ce retrait les gars
[Musique]
il est de retour et cette année on
emmène à fan2 de la suisse compte de la
[Musique]
m
le dream on
noé
[Musique]
je sais
des prix pour la journée là oui tu
t'habilles aujourd'hui alors je suis
dans le thème on se fait peur brésilien
ouais avec un big bang naissent à non
petites vidéos
mais gasquet du groupe choix qui allie
tard ce sera au jury que leur buteur
froid je regarde un peu la propre femme
âgée entre 12 à prester hermens
moi je peux sur le trail c'est bien tu
as quoi toi la reine des neiges on sait
qui c'est vrai que ça va continuer le
cliché est ce que c'est pas un truc
contestataires les bienvenus c'est pour
nous elle est venue et on fera de baroin
cuny enfants c'est pas normal et
vraiment c'est vraiment la société
par contre on va enlever votre casquette
de vendre et si oui en quoi je vais
acheter ça la crève
7 vous êtes français en fait
à laval très banal c'est votre création
7 chez vous et après vous avez des trucs
de ouf
exactement tout ça fait pas des artistes
français graphiste sénateurs territoire
recherche de boucles d'oreilles ou est
ce qu'on va trouver ça cool allait
arriver en reverse ça fait des années
que sur la vaisselle sans toi tu vas le
trou je vois tout le monde pas trop se
passe à se laisser liszt un peu devant
la russe pas trop tu vas le trône
derrière ou pas vous sentir enfin il
mais voilà vraiment
alors ces couches et c'est sur ces
bouchons [ __ ] de merde alors
l'alcool c'est pas mal
[Musique]
à quel moment peut croire que pelé nos
salons du prévenu non non c'est pas du
tout dit ça va dit quoi vous avez dit on
va les voir tous les maux et jeter un
raccourci pour le magasin playmobil
sastre et n'a aucun sens que tu arrives
est sûr que si on vous parlait toujours
l'abrogation l'abréviation et à emilien
napalm death
senna n'a pas lu la salle
[Musique]
ça va tu survis avec ses appuis ça
gratte moi madame à fromage
[Musique]
à
à qui mes rêves
lapointe comme quoi en fait la mauvaise
il ya un an
allez mon gars dont celle aller pour toi
mec tout ça les flots j'ai fais quoi
t'as vu quoi comme groupe de coulson et
aux [ __ ] on a vu des trucs salle ce
soir que sar est franchement way
hier on a vu quoi toi je rappelle juste
titre aux déchets c'était une demande
qui s'y fie à la mecque la cheminée sur
youtube et là il en slip dans un [ __ ]
et là il en slip dans un festoche c'est
dégueulasse réglages mais je l'aï connue
quand même si j'allais reconnu ça se
passe bien tanné sinon c'est génial
enfin peu moins en moins schopenhauer si
les gars moi mais le ciel est bleu c'est
magnifique ça va bien
un bon climat il ya un peu de vent mais
l'année dernière c'était l'enfer alex
mais le chanteur guitariste de
germanophones
là il ya une dédicace juste là pour ça
qu'elle accueille en fait on a juste
envie de le voir de loin tu vois bien
qu'on la laisse prendre à bouffer
[Musique]
elle intéresse de blé ok réveillez pas
cher et qu'est ce t'en pense alors des
groupes il fallait du temps il s'est
vraiment de la daube dumont ce fichier
on est arrivé hier on se fait chier
franchement tu arrives lot des grandes
banques
mais attends comprend les mecs qui font
des 15 heures de route nous on paie 40
box et fléchit la télé et j'ai été
obligé d'enlever mon t-shirt tellement
je me fais chier des joueurs de matinée
et rangement faut être con
[Musique]
je
c'est moutète pas l'heureux
[Musique]
tellement de
on a
[Musique]
les trois
gaylord l'élection de mister hellfest
servent à 9h à 20h sur la mainstage et l
élection de l'histoire il fallait
évidemment pas élu je pense que tu as tu
déjà fait des concerts un pas bien ou
quand j'ai vu beaucoup de concerts
qu'elle s'habille bien tu es là tu le
premier jour où par instigation trias
été ou de quoi asking alexandria c'était
pas mal et ça c'est vrai et ouais jouait
depuis jeudi soir au caire google c'est
quand le hellfest
[Musique]
crocheté n'est pas toujours à la
et
la nema
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vrai qu'avec sojasun c'est parce que je
suis tellement fait n'importe quoi
oui
sati vendeuse
j'ai bien joué j'ai
après c est notre week end en
championnat
on a bouffé des graines au stand sojasun
c'est génial
le repas stature
fêté par ses verbes faire
en fait les âmes ses peurs la page
j'ai peur
en vrac et qui n'a toujours pas compris
que c'était comment il s'appelle les nih
clinical habitants c'est quoi cette
chute à moto neige les bills motoneige
qui diffuse ce soir on va être interdite
duel fait sans votre aide et c'est pas
non plus les bateaux à moteur
nbc libye